[Music]
what up what up how you livin how you
doing my name is love goin I make good
music
I got B West until my left we are
through four weeks and got 12 left I
like that a little bit felt good okay so
the big question on everyone's mind is
Leonard fournette the best running back
of the end every week I could come and I
could do the same thing he had a heck of
a guy I am Perl there was a point in
that game I'm like what happened to a
porn net man yeah I thought he was good
he just it was it was nice having a
Sunday where I didn't have to worry
about the Eagles and I could watch all
the rest of the game I'm here the news
as we record Monday at around 2 o'clock
is vantes perfect is appealing a
suspension for the rest of the season I
feel a little bit responsible one of the
ditch the playbook episodes this year
was gonna be about fixing his karma mhm
me and a number we're gonna have him
walk old ladies across the street and
write apologies to everyone he's ever
harmed yeah if we would have been able
to get to him I think we could have
flipped this around and changed him as a
human but he's just he's just him doing
him apparently he's in London right now
with the team is he but he's not allowed
to do anything because he's peeling so
if you're in London you know by OMA by
Ahmad there's some fun things going on
in London too there are some nice things
to do there yeah yeah but what did you
think of the hit was obviously well no I
think that that type of thing should
absolutely be responded to this way by
the NFL there's just no room in the game
he had an opportunity to keep his head
up and target in a different place yeah
he took that opportunity to put his head
down here with the crown of his helmet
and when you saw like as someone that's
been concussed and stuff what do you
think I'm saying that's a nasty hit and
nasty meaning it's not a physical play
because it is physical but it's not like
you know he's just beat somebody up it's
a nasty hit and I don't think it has a
place in the game because again you know
and I'm not about the Brotherhood side
of things it's more like go
don't just just be smart about those
types of things just don't do that you
know
fortunately it's a repeated thing for
him this is how even plays everybody
else has changed their game just a
little bit see the penalties throughout
the games but he had an opportunity to
kid his head up and not try to do
exactly what he did
per the rules yeah in any and he just
didn't do it and obviously he doesn't
get in that's why he's suspended for the
whole seat it's so funny because like I
think of everything from a gambling
perspective so I was like their
defensive captain is out and they're
flying to London yeah oh man well who
made him captain
yeah I mean because this is what I think
about captains I think of responsible
men that are gonna walk it every single
day in a leader you can't waiver off
that centerline you got to be hey this
is the way you do it all the time and
that's the guy first year here that's
the guy that you made a captain that
just doesn't make any sense
who's that Khalil Mack manners yeah you
hear something that guy you wanting
something even more wild you know who
the Raiders play in London this week the
Bears
yeah I feel so bad for Derek Carr you
should that Khalil Mac as probably had
this game circled in his brain for two
years that's right and right now Khalil
Mac has four sacks for forced fumbles
and now he's facing his former team and
I don't know if you murder someone in
foreign waters can you be charged for it
in America you might not even be
suspended yeah I'm in football so no
yeah let's do it
I mean you know if this is succession I
think you get brought back and you get
put on trial but I Derek Carr I will if
you need me to look after your kids
well here's I gotcha bro think about
this if you're Derek Carr what I'm
saying and I used to say this about
Trotter like listen we're playing we're
doing like nine on seven the runs real
inside run I was like listen if you just
block that guy if you drop if you block
54 yeah we got a chance yeah we can I
get I make everybody else miss just
block that guy if I'm Derek Carr it's
pretty simple put two people on fifty
two side and make sure that he's
blocking three three put three over
there somebody block him I have I will
get into this a little bit later and
we're talking about great teams winning
ugly but this Chicago defense has
reached a point where like so
just a news alert to everybody I went
for and won in the super contest this
past weekend so now we're at 14 and six
one of mine with Chicago and I picked
that before the last injury reports come
out so I picked Chicago favor by one and
a half and Hakeem Hicks isn't playing
crap ro Quan Smith isn't playing yeah
crap yeah game starts off Mitchell sure
risky you know pops his shoulder out
hurt and I put on my paper a little X
and I said this skate was not for me to
win and that defense if you take away
that last drive by the Vikings that 92
yard drive when they were already down
16 to nothing there's like seven minutes
left the Vikings had a hundred and
thirty yards for the rest of the game
and this is without arguably their best
defensive tackle deterrent and their
starting middle linebacker and so I look
at Chicago and I go do I believe chase
Daniel or Mitchell true Biscay is gonna
be the guy that takes this team in the
promised land no but they have a top
five unit in the NFL
Kansas City's offense top five unit yeah
New England's defense top five unit
Chicago's defense top five unit Rams
offense but that Chicago D is so good
they'll never not be in a game what year
was that was it o-o one mm the the the
ravens where their defense was just so
dominant mm Ravens must've been 2000 rom
then there was the one Bears team with
Urlacher and Mike Brown and peanut
Tillman yeah they were unbelievable
turnover machine we saw this when Peyton
won the Super Bowl Denver Broncos that's
right
Von Miller and that defense and now like
Shaquille Barrett was a third-string
defensive lineman on the Broncos Super
Bowl team mm-hmm
that and right now he's leaving the NFL
insane crazy and and nobody could block
there are teams that can that one side
can carry the other side we've seen this
a million times
Peyton Manning carried his defense for a
damn near a deck yes sir
that's true but defense is nowadays you
can do so many things defensively
scoring wise yes getting the ball back
to your other team
show me the other side of the ball short
fields that's the difference right
that's why Chicago's well there's no
doubt about it the offense is average at
best I think that
Nagy does a decent job of changing some
things up formations things like that
but they just don't have the personnel
right now
at the quarterback position now I mean
they should be putting up a bunch of
points because they're getting the ball
back in good field position because of
how good that defense is it's it's crazy
to watch them play that defense
literally is a fast-break defense
they're getting the ball back to their
offense in every like docu-series and
stuff I always see coaches go we got to
win this quarter and how many coaches
have you played for broke this the
schedule up into four-game stretches all
of them all of them broke it up of
course was it always four would they be
like we have three games no you're all
always four because you're saying okay
let's win this one did this quarter it's
the quarter of the season win this
quarter of a season then we got another
stretch where it's like we have three
games on a road that's one quarter of
the season then the next quarter of
season we got three games at home there
for you guys to digest in the NFL is
such a week to weekly yeah I mean we see
it in the games I mean it's such a
week-to-week league so many things are
like okay well this week we have these
matchups and this makes us being able to
run yeah next week we playing you know a
team that is terrible against the past
yeah so we have to be weeks week we have
to be multiple offensively and
defensively so when we get to this part
where there are some teams out there
like the Chiefs they're high five and we
go at four now in the first Mormon and
there's other teams out there right now
like the Falcons where they're like
we're one in three yeah well let's turn
it around yeah what what happens in this
week take us inside these locker rooms
when it goes from the first quarter to
the second quarter are the losing teams
like let's flip it around or the winning
teams like what is the energy change
like well I don't know that the energy
is a change to become because we're now
in the fourth you know after the fourth
game second quarter the second quarter
things but I just think that now you
have a better idea of who you actually
are
okay we're this team we're let's say
we're the Detroit we're actually a team
that has ability to win we're working
we're competing yes last year we weren't
even close obviously you talked about
Miami we thought that we were doing
great things in the offseason and now we
we know that we're terrible but other
teams like let's say the Rams they came
into this season with serious Super Bowl
hopes and now you're like maybe they're
not as good so many people now have said
you know what San Francisco is the best
team in that division let's talk about
Seattle and the Rams are kind of at the
thought and so it happens across the
board but the thought in the lock
okay we got that out of our especially
nowadays September is a new August right
now I'm a date you're like okay now we
kind of got the training camp that the
jitters out of our body there's laying
week one how sloppy will buy we
different now
I'm just curious at like were you ever
on teams where it wasn't going well in
the first four weeks and then because
the whole mindset was we're on the
second quarter
you found yourself playing better in
that fifth game try to get an advantage
right well no I think that it was never
again it's never about the quarters when
you're the team it's not week to week so
it's not about you know the fifth games
coming now we got to turn it on it was
always like here the money the money
time in the NFL has always been late
October in November this is how you make
your Super Bowl your your playoff run
how you gonna play in November it really
discipline this is when the seahawks
always chests around this is when the
Patriots always get it together but this
year they're okay but we were never a
great team in September we we secured
and Erie used to beat us up in training
camp so there were so many times we were
like you know we're going into training
the first game of the season and we were
just okay we probably go to into first
couple games of the year first quarter
of the year then we would just turn it
on we would just rip some wins October
and November and that changes things now
you understand what you have is a team
now you understand that our offenses
need some help we need to be able to run
the ball more our defense needs some
help maybe we need to take up more time
on the clock offensively so now you know
what you are now you can address the
rest of the season this is a fourth the
fourth game of the year as we're looking
back what are some of the biggest
surprises for you as you look like the
pleasant ones and also I think the
biggest surprise for me and this is
there's a Rams I mean I'm disappointed
in Jared Goff I mean he's he's he's not
he's not the guy that I thought he was
six interceptions on a season four
turnovers yesterday I mean you know you
got paid you're gonna you know you're
making all this money you gotta take
care of the football yeah the biggest
thing in the NFL and I've watched all
the games I watched the red zone
yesterday is taking care of the football
that if you keep the ball you can win
any game your defense plays have halfway
decent you can keep the football the one
thing I'm watching this team and they're
averaging 43 passes again yeah I think
if you're like 68 or 64
three passes the game you're talking
about one of the best highest paid
running backs in week especially coming
into the year yeah Todd Gurley and
obviously there's trying to save him
he's averaging 12 carries a game yeah
they're trying to save them and I
understand that I was now just because
Tampa Bay jump shots like a 21 nothing
lead got rid of it but you're all better
educated on getting him the ball because
he is the engine that keeps this thing
going I think that's a major mistake
I'll throw on a [ __ ] III I think one of
my biggest surprises from last week was
Tampa Bay beating the Rams I thought
they they came out of nowhere I think
one of my pleasant surprises has to be
Gardner Minshew
I know it's a story that we talked about
last week but I don't think people
realize Denver
heading into this season was 19 and five
in home games in September we talked
about how September is the new August
when you play at Denver earlier in the
season it's typically a loss and for him
to be down 17 to 3 and some of the moves
he was making of getting around people
and throwing touchdowns Leonard
fournette was unbelievable but the
touchdown throws to DJ shark the one
that was called back yes the one where
he threw it to rock their backup running
back it's the notion that I'm seeing a
lot of quarterbacks that are backups
that I go they'll keep the win
chase Daniel Teddy Bridgewater but I
don't know if they're down if I fully
have confidence in bringing him back to
go win it and I've now seen Gardner
Minshew lead a comeback against Houston
and the coach took the ball out of his
hands for the two-point conversion and
really they could have gone to overtime
and they had all the momentum should I
see him dust up a Titans team that
Jacksonville has gotten dusted up by for
the last few years and then going to
Denver and Denver has five sacks in the
first half Von Miller notches his 100th
of his career crazy they can't do
anything and Gardner Minshew
is back there making it happen yeah and
so now I'm sitting here going I'm not
expecting a sixth-round pick in his
first year to figure out the NFL yet the
games probably still fast we we are
seeing what I look for is glimpses of
things to build upon and I see them and
to me it's no longer a gimmick yeah I'm
not interested in the mustache
don't give a [ __ ] what he wore on the
play he's a good player I'm going we
could have this guy on a cheap-ass
contract for four years that's how teams
win cuz he gets around to this Jackson
Ville defense that I thought they
weren't gonna be able to afford because
they just paid Nick Foles all that money
maybe they can keep some of those guys
maybe they can keep Jalen Ramsey maybe
that says I to them stuff I know it's
done but maybe he says you know what
maybe we're a little bit better than I
thought we were and maybe I am curious
if jaylen's gonna like have not played
yesterday and the team is so excited
right now
that he's gonna be like I kind of feel
like I'm left yeah yeah I kind of feel
left out and guess what my back feels
better I had to no we want to run back -
let me let me give you some things
really I'm not gonna Detroit Lions mmm
they took Casey to the wire yesterday I
said it took my homes magic to win this
thing and so now they're 2 1 & 1 which
when you think of week 1 obviously they
tied Arizona wits and they were
dominated that they got dominated week
two they beat the charges which is good
yeah big three day beat Philly so I'm
thinking maybe they got a chance this
defense is playing well offensively
they're throwing a ball all around the
place Golic day is just toe tapping his
butt into the end zone which is cool
it's pretty cool to see the Detroit
Lions because no one expected anything
from them and let me add this to this
what's incredible about that is they
fumbled twice that's right inside the
five yes
so that is not only just points off the
board one of those fumbles because it
was the same officiating crew that reft
Saints Rams did not blow the whistle
which allowed brashaad Breeland to run
99 yards for a touchdown
mahomes did not throw a touchdown they
had mahomes on their own on his own 30
in fourth and eight with the game on the
line
mm-hmm this is a Detroit team that has a
very good defensive front four they're
not gonna let you run the ball
luckily are they were they did not have
Darius slay playing yesterday easily
their best corner and I look at their
division and I go I have a lot of
questions about Green Bay Kirk Cousins I
have no faith in and the starting
quarterback of the Bears just went down
right the Lions have gotten very
interested a got very interested I'll
give you another one and I think a lot
of people saw this yesterday but the
Browns and I just went back to look at
it obviously got blown out week one for
3:13 blowout right everybody thinks now
you guys talk too much you know you're
out of the way the second week they beat
the Jets easy win the third week they
they had a chance to win against the
Rams yeah Baker Mayfield ends up
throwing the interceptions in the last
series that again they had a chance to
win that football game and then of
course they beat the Ravens differently
and now I'm starting to hear nothing
from the Browns they're not talking in
the media as much any maker came out
after the game kind of sense because it
Rex Ryan is overrated I'm okay with that
and Baker who who apparently is the
biggest Napoleon complex of all time
it's a chip on his shoulder I'm not okay
I love it I think my favorites but he
came out and he said you threw us in the
trash we'll remember the thing that I
loved about what I saw yesterday and we
have talked about this a lot about how
the Ravens have suffered against three
wide receivers yes and maybe this was
the perfect matchup for the Browns and
it ended up being so in Landry was the
beneficiary but what I saw at Freddy
kitchens was the play caller from old
Isola Jarvis Landry sweep that went for
about 40 50 yards I saw Nick Chubb
getting the ball in different such [ __ ]
I just saw him getting the ball Nick
Tarrant I saw an Odell Beckham reverse
throw that the receiver should have
caught and so when I see him going into
his bag of tricks creativity it was as
if he thought he could come in this year
with Odell and Landry and go we're just
gonna beat you face out huh but I think
it was important for me yesterday to see
him using guys like Ricky seals Jones
and going he's finally realizing I need
to coach him up and that gives me a lot
of faith for the Browns moving not only
do I need to coach him up how about I
spread the ball around the best offenses
are the ones that are not predictable
that you're not saying I'm gonna throw
the ball to Odell Beckham jr. 13 times
how about I get Jarvis Landry who is a
pretty doggone good player that's the
ball from time to time how about we run
the football Nick Chubb 165 yards just
getting off looking good looking faster
than I thought he was I mean that's how
you that's what you do to a defense you
spread them out you get the ball and you
look for the best matchups yesterday
Jarvis Landry was the best matchup
that's why he got the football that's
where Freddie kitchens has to do my big
thing that I learned yesterday was
there's the phrase you know good teams
win great teams cover mm-hmm that's for
gambling for real life great teams win
ugly average teams lose ugly right so
the great teams that one ugly yesterday
Kansas City ugly game mahomes doesn't
throw a touchdown by the way short
shout-out to Harley Kate Minh I asked on
the left coast show account how many
yards will mahomes throw she guessed 315
he had 350 now to New England listen to
this New England had seven three and
outs against Buffalo a four and out and
a 5 and out so 9 drives where they
barely move the ball 20 yards down the
field and they go and they win that game
you great teams win ugly New Orleans New
Orleans kicks four field goals and
they're able to beat the Dallas Cowboys
you win ugly and you know what I also
want to give the credit to the Chicago
Bears right that was an ugly game their
offense you know little spurts here and
there but those four teams were great
and I look at Kansas City in New England
Kansas City in New England right now or
easily the two best teams in the sport
no doubt and it's everybody else and and
on Sunday they were thanos in which it
looked like they had been slaughtered
and then in that moment they looked at
their opponents and said you should have
gone for the head Kansas City was down
fourth and eight mahomes runs for twenty
yards
bing-bang-boom he threw it he threw it
to a guy on their team named Pringle
yeah and I went who the [ __ ] is this guy
just to catch John game over here but
just a guy that's fast that's what he
that's a ball just throw the ball to
someone fast they're holding on to a 16
to 10 lead Buffalo has the ball first
and goal on the eighth and they
eventually get an interception off a tip
pass on Matt Barkley and they seal the
game these are teams where if you don't
kill them yeah
Detroit was up 10 nothing if you don't
kill them they will thanos your ass and
you never exist in these games
these are critical games I talked to the
trainer good friend of mine it was in
Philadelphia for to Kansas City and this
is where Andy Reid's holding the ball
old guy no no Rick Burkholder okay a
poor guy so he yeah he a little hair but
I said to him in the text message these
are the games that build the character
for November and December he said that's
exactly what Andy said to the team yes
is that correct in fact this is what he
said to the team and it's one of my
favorite quotes of the week this is in
the lock loop it's such an Andy quote
not all of Mozart's paintings are
perfect but at the end of the day they
sell it for a million long as you win
long as you get a W that's all that
counts I'm gonna tell you this though
I'm a little worried about it Kansas
City okay I'm worried about this week on
it I mean I think Matt Stafford is a
decent quarterback at this point in his
career I think he has a really good
receive he looks better this year than
he ever did last and I don't know how
but new haryana Johnson yeah got off
against that defense got a date
obviously catching a football Matt
Stafford three touchdowns I'm concerned
about that detall thing about that they
were gonna get better
the Chiefs got run on well they do have
one guy coming back from suspension
they're getting Morris Morris Claiborne
back who's a very solid corner no team
just picked him up as he was suspended
for four weeks but Detroit ran all over
him yeah Baltimore round on over him
they started off down ten nothing to the
Raiders didn't week two and week one
they were just you know they were up and
back with Jacksonville Gardner Minshew
lit him up for like 200 300 yards it's
hard to come back every single week
especially as a season gets are with
them it's just I'm trying to tell you
it's hard and it gets tiresome at some
point your defense has to show up at
some point your office is not gonna have
it every every week we don't need to see
my home was imagine I'm telling you that
he's gonna have it every week well I
hope so I'll be the hot tape if I'm the
coach I'm saying defense show up a
little bit how about how about we don't
have to go score 10 points in the fourth
quarter yes how about that I'm a little
concerned about that I'm gonna give you
one thing that I'm disoriented about the
Houston Texans deshaun Watson 18 sacks
already it was sacked 62 times like he's
on track to be sacked 72 times this
season
Wow and they just
- first in a second for Laremy Tunsil
maybe it's just not the left tackle
maybe it's a little bit of the offensive
line maybe we need a coach up to Shawn
watching a little bit morning I'm not
I'm not gonna listen he didn't have a
terrible game yeah I think he could play
better but there's a point where you're
saying one two three get the ball out
one two three point five five step drive
get the ball out maybe I get the ball
out a little bit more especially if I
know my blocking is it there he has to
find a different way they're gonna kill
this kid down there there was a Watson
clip that was sort of making the way the
rounds where a reporter asked about you
know you missed on your two deep shots
and I wrote down the two quarterbacks
last week that narratives are so funny
in the NFL deshaun Watson had will
fuller wide open on a post missed him by
two yards had a Hopkins on a poster
missed him if they complete either of
those passes they win the game and it's
over Kirk Cousins miss Phelan and digs
deep two times he hits either of those
they win the games - it's just funny
that the NFL it can really change on one
play but Watson went into a whole speech
and people were debating online whether
he owned the reporter which who the [ __ ]
cares that but he broke it down
understands the deep and I have I have
now been around deshaun Watson one time
with Sims were they were talking for 15
minutes using Patriots terminology that
I've I don't even know what any of it
[ __ ] meant and I could see the way
Watson's brain works I have so much
confidence in Watson my issue with them
is Bill O'Brien and it's always been my
issue with them that he can have the
most talented people and it will be
completely neglected but that's why
that's why when you ask me why am i down
on Houston belly they can beat a team
and they'll beat themselves before
they're allowed to beat the team the New
England I went into my issue with New
Orleans my only issue with the game last
night yeah was I talked about how there
was the referee staff that didn't blow
the whistle for Detroit referees this is
an advantage for New Orleans
I believe that referees are afraid to
make calls against the Saints in New
Orleans yeah because there was like five
instances on that game where I went
what's going on Zeke did not fumble on
that fourth and was not
but they were afraid to over to his
knees elbow was clearly down way down at
the end of the half there's two seconds
on the clock they go to run the play and
the announcer al michaels goes I've
always been told it's impossible to run
a play with two seconds I thought it was
four seconds they throw it incomplete
pass and there's magically to set like
one second still left impossible and I
so the play clock four seconds went off
and I'm watching and I'm going I think
they're afraid to call penalties against
the Saints well III don't want to say
justice I think the Saints are certainly
a big-time part of that I mean they wore
blind referee costumes all offseason
absolutely that's the big part but I was
I'm watching the red zone yesterday and
referees are missing calls across
they're missing calls when they go to
replay they're purposely they're missing
Connor whistles and it creates like the
thing I don't like about it is when a
defense they don't blow the whistle and
they run 60 yards for a touchdown and
they all run down there and they all
take a photo and all that energy and
they're high-fiving and then the referee
goes out there goes we're gonna
challenge it well I just think that has
to impact the defense to experience that
impacts a defense but they just remember
in a Kansas City game they yeah that was
a tough day I believe that but that he
could have been tackled right there I
musta Mancala day that was right there
but it's natural for at the player to
say okay I'm not gonna attack tackle
them I'm gonna get a penalty because the
whistle has blown the play is over so
he's thinking that the play is over how
about this when they're not blowing the
whistle you're like what we had on
Thursday night when Packers fans were
furious that Derek Barnett came in there
and hit that guy yeah Williams yeah yeah
yeah the whistle wasn't blown no and so
what's happening is is we're telling
these guys play throughout the whistle
yeah because we don't know what's gonna
happen but then we're also kind of
endangering our players because we're
not blowing the [ __ ] whistle that's
true that's true is really really hard I
think that the referees have to play
play a big part in that do it if you do
your job right we wouldn't have to go in
it make so many of these judgment calls
especially when it comes to the replay
sir so I talked about the
the four teams that one ugly and they
show that they can be great yeah
Kansas City New England New Orleans
Chicago for me the ugly losses which let
me know that you're not a great team yet
Baltimore the Rams
Dallas Minnesota and Indy I saw holes in
all of them that I have a huge issue
with right now with Indy this defense is
letting up a lot of points a young
people and they were really really good
last year they were they were solid and
losing Darius Leonard is clearly a huge
impact
Minnesota I have no faith in your
passing game Kirk Cousins nothing and I
don't even want to say just Kirk because
I'm like what NFL teams only keep four
receivers lose one and then only run
routes with two receivers yeah and then
Dallas that that high-and-mighty offense
where we saw them put up points on
Washington New York and Miami and now
you play New Orleans it just it makes me
go I still think you're a really good
team if Tyron Smith is out I have a lot
of questions but it makes me go I have a
lot to evaluate the Rams you just don't
let that happen you're not a great team
if you allow 57 points no you use
absolutely not think about Dallas I'm
thinking going into this game I in my
mind they're gonna run the football this
is a Zeke game yeah and they just
couldn't do it 18 karat 18 carries is a
lot of carries that that's enough for
Zeke you know and usually he's a 25
carry a game type of guy but when you're
not having any success averaging less
than a yard per carry not lasting less
than two yards of carry that's just not
gonna be enough and you add that to the
situation where that really means that
play I can pass he really really means
that and I know the first few games he
didn't because you playing inferior
competition but he I think but that's
what you see the thing that's really
interesting to me and we'll learn about
this with coaches as the year goes on is
they had all the play calls the first
three weeks and a lot of it was
predicated on play action but when the
game got tight so did Kellen Moore yes
and Kellen Moore started running a lot
on first down which you don't forgive
the other thing that I just want to say
is that I look at this Saints team and
I'm gonna get into a little bit more
later
I think the Saints might have the best
defensive line in the NFL I mean this is
a team that didn't have Sheldon Rankin's
and he's just getting back but some of
their defensive lineman and cam Jordan
no one has run on them Gurley didn't run
on him
Zeke didn't run on him who they they
play the beginning I remember but
they're off their defense has been
amazing the entire time I'm gonna get
into it later
the only other note that I wanted to get
into about something to pay attention
the one analytic Westbrook that the
thing that people focus on is yards per
play yeah that when a game is over you
could tell who the better team was by
yards per play so one thing I think I'm
just gonna keep updating everybody on
Mondays is the teams that had better
yards per play but lost because they
lost the turnover battle and the reason
this is good for us is it'll go Wow that
team actually played the other team
right they just [ __ ] up and maybe
people are gonna get harder on them than
they should be
okay I have four games and this happened
Green Bay out gained Philadelphia a yard
per play and lost the turnover battle to
nothing would you agree with me that the
Packers were maybe the better team in
that game I think they were the better
team and I also think they're inside the
five a couple times and didn't score
yeah they had two drives the end of the
game inside the five so what are you
doing to run the ball one time what are
you doing
young offensive coordinator not look
younger called play caller is doing this
is the same offensive coordinator that
Tennessee last year he was there Osteen
had the ball inside the five in London
and they didn't run it with Derek Henry
one time the biggest running back in the
league what are you doing so but but
because it's making me feel but it also
gives me more confidence in Green Bay
and it also makes me look at
Philadelphia and go okay they got out of
there with the wind which is huge but
maybe not as confident well I thought
that going into that game I thought the
Philadelphia was at a disadvantage short
week obviously on the road playing a
very good quarterback I kind of felt
like they had a big time opportunity to
lose that game they fought back figured
our way out to win
I think Carson will just play out of his
mind he played better than he had all
season long guys actually caught the
football and guess what it's really
really nice to have a running game ask
Gardner Minshew even when Leonard
fournette
goes off with 225 Dallas Connor was
amazing foul shot was amazing prism and
I look at it like this too
if they go oh let me just see you can go
to one you can go 21 yeah 21 twelve
twelve twelve two tight ends one running
me here right now what the Eagles did so
well against Green Bay was we're gonna
put Dallas Connor and Zach Ertz out
there with a running back al Shawn and
then another wide receiver if we run it
we're gonna overpower you that's right
if we play action you're so worried
about the run that we have al Shawn
coming back on that 10-yard comeback but
guess what happens when DeSean comes
back and they do the play-action and you
pump it to Al shots right - Shawn's
going 50 yards you know what the offense
will be beautiful i watching a game and
I think everybody people know this but
it was it was a thing of beauty
Zach Ertz is always open every single
play every single play and so many
people were like well why does a KERS
have a hundred and fifteen catches last
year whatever it was broke my record I
had 90 he just demolished it it's
because he's open on every play they
tried to check him with a safety he's
open quarterback he's open linebacker
dating we tried that Nate he just start
double-team at him he's always open he
it's it's kind of remarkable and I think
Travis Kelce is probably the best
in-game but Zach Ertz I mean what he's
doing is pretty pretty cool I still
would have Kelsey and Kittel kid oh yeah
it was really really fast but I think
and I think people want to put Darren
Waller above hurts he's not above her
Tara Wallace he's just bought he's
caught 33 passes he's an amazing that's
pretty good oh my you said before the
game what was your confidence in the
Eagles 0.5 0.5 and you were a 6.9 sexy
that was pretty number and I but there
they are the underdog team now the
question is can they maintain being
underdogs well how do you do that
because that has to be a roller coaster
don't know in order to be a underdog you
kind of have to look what's your number
now it's gone up it's gone up a lot
because now I'm seeing first of all this
is what I saw from Doug I saw a much
better play caller very much I think
when you have a run game it just loosens
him up as a play caller I also think
that miles Sanders figure something out
Jordan Howard figure something out and I
think Doug as a play call to figure
something out if you put them at the top
of the eye they can go downhill and they
can make cuts instead of going sideways
they can go downhill don't fit your
players into
your offense build an office around your
players what's a quarterback underneath
the center he did he was great and they
look good and also so I was a six point
nine last week I am a six point nine
this week okay you saying the same I
they are they did what I expected them
to do I'm not gonna get crazy here but I
look at the Eagles great matchup with
the Jets this weekend absolutely like
this is exactly what the doctor called
for I don't know if they cover the 14
I'm not touching that [ __ ] line
because there's officer pie and who the
hell knows but they're so the the
Packers out gain the Eagles lost the
turnover battle right so the Packers are
probably better than people are reacting
to another game Buffalo out gain New
England by one point seven yards per
play they incredible and lost the
turnover margin four to one Buffalo is
better than we think they are I think
they are nasty defense opportunistic
defense they get after the quarterback
and that's what you want and in a
shout-out to my cahide for that amazing
intercepts great interception thank you
for letting me hit my first half under
going into the game Tom Brady had three
touchdowns in the last two years against
that Buffalo defense and four
interceptions that defenses opportunites
they understand what Thomas trying to do
but they got a bunch of guys in their
front seven that you just really
probably couldn't point out in a
Darkling minor but the thing about the
the bills too is they they've always had
a decided home-field advantage they are
a waterboy team mm-hmm I have more
confidence when the bills defenses on
the field than when they're offensive I
thought they had a better chance to
score a touchdown yesterday with their
defense then with 12 something my nose
no okay you feel like yeah I did but I
felt like the Bills had more cut I had
more comments in the bills scoring on
defense history than offense I was more
afraid the Patriots were gonna score
when they're defenseless little field
then when their offense I'm watching a
red zone in a personal shout out there
for eternity
McDermott knows every space no he nature
it's tried absolutely no so he
understands that Frank eg 15,000 yard
Wow just got eclipsed to 15,000 you know
that's that's pretty darn awesome we
talked about that's the way I think you
have to beat the Patriots I don't think
you're gonna throw on that secondary no
no but this is the thing so I'm watching
the red zone and it would go back and
forth and every time I went back
again the Patriots were punting yeah
honey honey I mean it was amazing
because it would be two minutes no
injury knives three and drives of a
first town or less it was it was
impressive great job defense there are
two teams that lost but out gained the
other team per play Denver out game
Jacksonville per play by almost a yard
and lost a turnover battle one nothing
they were the better team until Gardner
Minshew and Leonard fournette one off
and Dallas out gain New Orleans by a
half a yard 4.8 to 4.3 and they lost the
turnover battle three to one and in all
those situations I do in a weird way
have a lot of confidence in Dallas
Buffalo and Green Bay Denver I just
don't bet on teams that have Joe Flacco
that's just my rule Joe Flacco had a
decent day obviously he had an
interception when I watched the game I'm
saying hey you're leading most of this
game why does Phillip Lindsey only carry
the ball nine times and in for 53 yards
so he was averaging over five yards of
carry almost close to six yards ok why I
don't understand you're leading you're
winning
keep the ball away from the other team
yeah how does that happen I think it's
just a lot of these defensive coach
teams Zimmer is like this I'm sure Vic
Fangio is like this when they get a lead
they go to their OC and they go let's
get conservative and when you're playing
a defense like Jacksonville if you're
gonna go heavy and run you're probably
not gonna get a lot of first downs and
the problem is is we were talking about
young quarterback sort of like the chase
Daniels I don't expect him to win the
game right I felt that way about Joe
Flacco for the last five years no no but
I'm saying they ran the ball 15 times
total in the game they're up 17 is six
at half time that's crazy
now but time to run the football now
it's time to get down hill Phillip Lizzy
is a really good running back so I don't
think a lot of people know this about
Brian Westbrook but Brian Westbrook
considers himself a little bit of an
entrepreneur I try you are very big into
venture capital which means that you've
been pitched many businesses over the
years yes and you invest in some then
level and and some of them probably a
lot you don't you see holes in it so
yeah you got it
I mean when you in that game you gotta
say hey these 96% of the businesses out
of here do you believe that that's given
you a better mindset for evaluating
things
that you should buy low on and things
that maybe aren't really up your up here
I would hope so yes great I think so so
what we're gonna do here is a little bit
of NFL venture capital a little thing
that we like to call the dolphin tank
because they're tanking and kind of a
shark and I have three football opinions
okay that I am going to pitch to you and
I want to know if you're interested in
buying okay so let us go into the
dolphin tank with my first pitch do it
now entering the tank Adam let go is a
football entrepreneur hoping to get an
investment in his innovative NFL takes
but he'll have to impress Eagles legend
than current venture capitalist Brian
Westbrook
this is dolphin tech first up left goes
got an outside-the-box playoff team that
no one besides him saw coming he's
looking for $100,000 in exchange for a
25% stake in this
hmm this is a $400,000 take okay okay I
have a team for you Brian Westbrook
their top ten in passing offense okay
their top five in points per game they
are the number one team in the NFL at
stopping the run and on third down
their top ten defense and top five in
the red zone are you interested in this
team at two and two making around the
playoffs so we got them a top ten top
ten in passing yes top five in points
per game points when the number one
defense the NFL in stopping the run
stopping around two and two right I said
that means they get passed on all the
time pretty well but their defense is
top ten on third down so they get off
the field
yeah and their top five in red zone Kent
can I can I know who they lost to no I
can't I can't get that they've lost to
an undefeated team yeah and they lost to
a 500 team I have problems with teams
that struggle stopping the pass let me
tell you what their passes that that to
me because again we're dissipation Lee
you need to have all the information I
know all the information we used when
you struggle to stop the pass that's a
problem I'm not great at stopping and
here's the thing will you tell me that
they're really good at red zone defense
I'm not saying that this is always the
case but you may be great at red zone
and that means you may but you may have
allowed a team get in there twice
you're know they haven't scored two
times but you may be giving up the big
play which is just as bad right as it
has given up a red zone touchdown
that's that concerns me so to me what
I'd be interested in that they're number
one in passing offense or scoring
they're our top ten in passing offense
top five in scoring in their - and - I'm
gonna say my initial thought is no damn
no I'm not asking the team was the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers oh here's the thing about
the Buccaneers they've beaten Carolina
yes in Carolina yes
they beat the Los Angeles Rams in Los
Angeles and they should come out yes
they were beating the crap out of the
Giants and missed a field goal yeah and
in their loss to San Francisco Jameis
through to pick sixes and has looked 10
times better since through and their
defense Todd Bowles has played I mean
we're right about this though your
venture capitalist skills helped they
were they're taught they're number one
in inrush defense their 31st and pass
teeth that's a problem but I look at the
Bucks right now and I go there one field
go away from three and one that's right
and beating Carolina in LA or not just
playoff contenders I think they're both
teams that could maybe represent the NFC
so what do you think now that you know
where the team is I I'll say this I
think you're right save it till later
yeah I have to say no okay
no but I do appreciate that Jameis looks
much much better
I do appreciate their defense looks
legit I think Ronald Jones you know in
the first row is a good running back to
me all rode off in the first four weeks
he's had three out of the first four
weeks he's had nothing less than 70
yards rushing so I don't know lunging
hardest he runs hard because last year
you couldn't find Ronald Jones he also
had like a 60 yard run yesterday that
was brought back by a holding which I
value
he looks good he's averaging four-point
yards a carry that's impressive I'm
concerned though I'm concerned with them
having success I'm also concerned that
Jameis likes to throw the ball to the
other team
he hasn't proved to me that that's not
fixed yet but he's looked pretty dog
going good seven touchdowns the two
interceptions the last two games that's
not bad alright so I wasn't able to sell
you there yeah yeah that was a really
good company all right let's get to my
second pitch that was a really good
company
[Applause]
next up left goes the proud owner of a
secretly great defense that's gotten a
bum rap this year but he needs an
injection of cold heart agreement to
take things to the next level he's
hoping to secure $500,000 in exchange
for a 10% stake in this event that's
right it's a five million dollar opinion
Brian Westbrook expensive when offense
has faced this team this defense they
get a sack 11 percent of the time third
best in the NFL when the ball goes in
the air
this defense intercepts at three percent
of the time fifth best in the NFL and in
terms of third down defense this team
gets off the field top five in the NFL
they sacked the quarterback they get
interceptions they have a great third
down defense and I'm gonna give you a
little bit of inside information so much
of their secondary has been hurt that we
haven't even seen the starters in for
more than half the season are you buying
my defense as a great defense
I love defenses that can get out to the
quarterback I love defenses that get off
the field on third down yeah I love if
you if you want to know I'll even let
you know where they rank yeah what's
there what's the record I mean can you
can you tell me their record or no 2 & 2
2 & 2
ok I'm trying to give you bi-lo
candidates okay hey you could sell high
okay this team is 13th against the pass
yeah 14th against the rush so you
combine the fact that they're right
around there and they're third and sack
percentage and they're they're right up
there they're right up there towards the
top in interception percentage
I love teams that get off the field I
mean I absolutely do
my concern is their offensive production
cuz we're talking about huh oh you oh no
I'm not I don't know who it is but okay
you didn't mention anything about the
offensive production meaning their
defense gets off the field they do a lot
of it a lot of good things but
offensively they probably struggle they
probably spend a lot of time I actually
got that wrong there's 7th against the
past and their 21st against the run I
just I just wanted to clear that up I
think
then their their offense is 14th in
rushing and 13th in passing do you buy
this but we're talking about the defense
I think this is a great defense I'll
give you one more hint it's a defense
that you [ __ ] on a few weeks ago yeah I
am and they're 2 & 2 now I love great
defenses because they generally last the
test of time however if their offenses
average those defenses get worn down
just a bit we saw that in Jacksonville
last year defense just wore down and
they just dying my fundation dollars
they started giving up again I love
great deep it you didn't miss an office
and that that kind of makes me think
that the offense is not very good
offense hung up over 40 points this week
this week I am I'll buy that I'll buy
that you just bought the Cleveland
Browns defense the same defense that you
said was worse than Miami Dolphins yeah
I'd like to explain this really quick
the Cleveland Browns defense if you take
away and I know people don't like to do
this they get very angry if you take
away the Derrick Henry screen pass in
week one 75 yard play the Browns are
tied with the bills for the 4th best
pass defense in the NFL
letting up less than 200 yards per game
they went out there yesterday damarious
Randall sacked Lamar Jackson by himself
Jermaine Whitehead got a Jermaine white
it they they have not had greedy
Williams or who was their first pick
last year their cornerback I know you
talking about wart yeah get it at play
like the last two weeks they shut down
Jared Goff Tennessee that was an outlier
when we look at it now and what they
just did to Baltimore this is a great
Cleveland Browns defense and you just
bought them for five million I don't
know that I don't know that i think that
teams are gonna catch up with baltimore
so i all ffensive LY i don't think that
they're that juggernaut that everyone
kind of thought they were I think that
they're sold I'm still on the Ravens
bandwagon I I'm glad you are I think
that I think that this team offensively
will get better I think this team will
get better which will help that defense
and I think that once they got rid of
all of the outside stuff the talking
just focus on your football yeah this
time
on the team the reason why everyone is
picking this team early on because
there's a bunch of towel and they were
concerned with with with talking a good
game instead of walking it now this team
looks like they were ready to walk it
and they got out of that talking face
now you're real he goes this morning
walk I like you talking like you tell
you like they mm I might have listened
to on the way I look at the Browns and I
go their safeties have been out there
corners have now got a bunch of injuries
yeah when those guys get back the Browns
are gonna go on a run I think they I
think you too they should that's why I
bought it
yeah good defenses Jeter you're
supporting in the browser
I'd like to browse now I'm like first of
all I like what they were able to do
against the rain yeah I appreciate that
even though you know there were some
things that they I think they should do
differently I appreciated what they were
able to do in a divisional game on the
road that's important putting up 40
points on the road that's hard to do I
don't think they did a good job
one thing I'll say because I've been
such a staunch defender of the Ravens is
if you look at this this came in the
beginning of the second half it's 10 to
10 mm-hm and we're starting to see what
we've seen Mars run in your Ingram's
running everything looks great and then
Ricky seals Joan gets a 60 yard catch
pick it Browns he's huge it in for
touchdown I'm not support six goodness
great and then so it's 1710 Ingram
fumbles while they're driving turnover
Browns get a touchdown to two touchdown
lead and just like that suffer but the
Ravens were they were still playing well
other than that I have one more shark
tank let's do it well excuse me one more
dunking tank let's set it up finally
left goes breaking new ground with his
Defensive Player of the Year pic but he
won't settle for anything less than two
million dollars in exchange for 0.2
percent equity stake
yeah that's right it's a billion-dollar
idea sharks
let me tell you do you have problems
wiping with your left hand not anymore
not with left wipe from the makers of
left Co okay so I have a Defensive
Player of the Year candidate that no
one's talking about okay and that's why
it's a billion dollar idea this player
in the NFL is top 10 in sacks this
player is second in the NFL in
interceptions hmm
this player is it among the lead leaders
and passes defended and his defense if
you care about team is best in the NFL
in yards and points per game number one
please stop cheating and looking up
teams well yeah no you're gonna invest a
billion dollars into my super-secret
Defensive Player of the Year that's
right top ten in sacks number two in
interceptions
now that you've looked him up haven't
looked at Meyer I'm not looking him up
this is often see that Keenan Allen you
see all these guys here you just office
no I'm gonna at the top nobody believes
you all right so do you buy it top ten
what do you think top number one defense
so he's on the number one defense okay
second in the NFL in interceptions okay
top ten in sacks don't see that off you
don't see that we're in do I buy him do
you buy my buy low take this guy how is
it a buy low take it if there's a
billion dollars how's that possible
because it's that good that it's gonna
turn that's that's a terrible billion
dollars I think I think defensive
players are huge if you can sack the
quarterback and you could get
interceptions with probably's anomaly
early on in a year get a couple of
deflections so that kind of makes sense
you're gonna buy it I think a billion
dollars is pretty doggone high that's
what we're getting at it's evaluation I
love the fact that he can sack the
quarterback and I think in this league
that changes and moves the needle we
talked we talked about also rolling on
Iran you don't even know who the [ __ ]
I'm talking about I know are you buying
I'm trying to give you my point okay
this is the reason why I would buy
because if you can get the ball back
that allows average teams to look pretty
good yeah if you could do that that
changes things
now the evaluation probably is all off
I'm just gonna ignore that because I
don't know that your math or arithmetic
is that good
you're gonna negotiate you just want my
royalty I want much more yeah I need my
I need much more than that it's not a
billion-dollar business you have no
sales at this point because it's all
need a quarter pole we have Caesar for
now we're allowing less than seven
points per game on this defense and this
guy is three interceptions and three and
a half sacks that counts billion dollars
is not okay do you want to know who you
just bought who Jamie Collins Haley
Jamie Collins he's impressive top ten
the NFL with three and a half sacks
second in the NFL with three
interceptions only behind his teammate
Devin McCourty isn't that crazy man no
he's been playing like okay who's that
is the magic of Bill Belichick yep Ben
let's check dressed Jamie Collins in the
second round and everybody goes whoo
yeah and he goes out there and he builds
him up into this player that the Browns
feel the need to give him twenty seven
million dollar contract to thread ship
him out he is so underwhelming that they
cut bait within a year or two and now
he's back on the Patriots and his top
ten in sacks and number two interception
he's humbled and came back and now he's
ready to play that defense is is nice so
my other people that I would say are up
right now for Defensive Player of the
Year again a quarter of the way through
Shaquille Barrett for Shaquille Barrett
yes nine sacks three forced fumbles [ __ ]
one interception he got that last week
incredible track Khalil Mack four sacks
for forced fumbles Aaron Donald I didn't
even look up his stats they don't matter
no he's Aaron Donald he changes ever
come back right now she's probably the
front-runner for plate and Devin
McCourty who has four interceptions and
four games and I do I would say that
it's between for me
Barrett Mack and McCourty I said got
Collins a little bit just but his
statistics are unbelievable to numbers
right because the thing is is right now
the Patriots are allowing six point
eight six point eight points per game
right and if that continues this could
be one of the greatest defensive perfect
now they just played Josh Allen who
likes to turn the ball over they played
Miami
they played Luke Falk this will not
continue no
there has been act getting for forced
fumbles and for games McCourty getting
four interceptions and four games
it's not that sustainable and what
Shaquille Barrett is doing is it might
be his career-high for a season it's
crazy what he's doing because he's
getting out the ball but I think that we
talked about that New England defense
they're special because they could do
two things and it's critical to winning
football games and in the field they can
get out to the quarterback affect them
in a lot of different ways batted balls
making the move things like that and
then on the secondary I think it's got
some dogs back there that debt our ball
Hawks
they're taking the ball away and again I
mentioned early this is why I think
that's a valuable proposition is because
when you can take the ball away the
other team they have no chance of
winning we are we kind of saw it in the
Buffalo game they're taking the ball
away from you no interception in the end
zone they're starting all their drives
like the 40 it's a different game
Buffalo you can have a great defense New
England wins that game by 30 field
position I mean the field position game
is a totally different thing I love that
defense nobody for New England whatever
when defensive played a year Stefan
Stefan Gilmore chasin McCourty is good -
Jones JC Jackson Devin McCourty Patrick
Jung yeah there's not a weak spot in
there no not a weak spot a very very
good players I just don't know that that
people would give them the defensive
play to here because they it kind of
feels like it's Bill Belichick's defense
not just one person if you talk about
the Chicago Bears you're saying oh
that's Khalil max defense that's that's
the guy that makes that thing go in
Buffalo just miss Isabella doe Belichick
right now is my coach of the year really
yes I don't I don't [ __ ] care about
Bruce Arians surprising people
maybe Kyle Shannon maybe who's for now
but don't forget that people thought
that the Patriots didn't really have a
wide receiver and what are they gonna do
without Gronk and they lost two tackles
and their Center goes down and you look
at their defense and you go oh it's
really good they're gonna have to do
everything and I'm gonna lose Brian
Flores and a Patricia in back-to-back
off seasons and he is calling the
defense now and they're averaging six
point eight points per game
Bill Belichick no should be every year
the coach of the year that's why I mean
right now he's doing it like no one's
ever done that that's why he won't win
it he can't be the coach to you you
still had the best player in football
Brady got the best player at the Tom
Brady threw for a hundred and fifty yes
I know and looked every bit of 42 years
old I know and Bill Belichick's defense
given the ball like four times inside
the 450 that's why the Patriots are
amazing I know you can take away both
hands and a foot and Belichick is still
gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you at the
other end they made a bunch of mistakes
yesterday including an interception and
they still wonderful ball game and
that's Belichick the small things I will
go with Matt Patricia right now just
because I like the way their team is
playing and they'll fight and look at
you Brian was right Matt hey listen Bill
Belichick is not gonna win another award
I mean come on how many words is this
guy want to win I mean as many as he
just let someone else win an award
no he's fair [ __ ] that share no we're
doing that [ __ ] I know who you are I
know you don't want your kids to get
participating one with the Patriots to
win anymore I just because of 2005 yes
that's the primer get over I would like
to have a ring one of these fingers a
ring that says Super Bowl champions with
the Eagles ever give your ring for their
last Super Bowl or Zep no no I kind of
thought like I was working for the team
at the time doing some medias yeah maybe
they'll throw me a ring just to kind of
you know hey you're in the Ring of Honor
here's a ring just to know didn't even
call to ask my ring side yet that would
be nice
[ __ ] Ronnie Harris and [ __ ] I'm wide
open in the end zone
all that Donna has to do is put it up I
know at the end of the half he throws it
to him Joe at the end of the hammer know
that to me I don't know I don't know I'm
gonna tell you about I will say this
though his throw to you for the actual
touchdown that was a good one of the
greatest three throw yeah great throw
great throw but I want to tell you about
somebody that I'm loving writing do you
want to do it and shoot your shot yeah
let's do okay so we're gonna do shoot
your shot this is when we try and come
up with opinions that we really strongly
believe that even if people are talking
about they're not talking about strong
enough yeah and if they're not talking
about it you gonna learn today yeah all
right so lead us off I think that
Jacksonville the Jacksonville Jaguars
are the best team in the AFC South
welcome to my world
are you in there too are you in there
division before the year really yeah are
you in the hot tubs at the top of the
stadium doing the games and stuff
I think Joanna I really want to see what
happens with Ramsey but I'd like to hear
your reasoning I just think that
obviously defensively they were
good last year anybody defensively but
they got ran down because they couldn't
stay on the field mission is earlier if
some reason some crazy reason jigna
Ramsey says you know what maybe we have
something here for some reason maybe
I'll just take up the owner on the
seven-year 77 million dollar contract he
kind of conveniently thrown out there
threw out there maybe we have something
maybe this Gardner Minshew can actually
win us some game maybe with the
assistance of fournette and his running
style we can win some games and you know
what we could be the best in the league
will make somebody come here
place at our house and I remember when
two years ago when the Patriots came
there and the Jaguars should have won
that football game right maybe if
they're saying you know what maybe our
team is a little bit better than that
team because we got a quarterback
there's willing to throw the football
down the road instead of Blake bortles
that was trying to throw the ball and be
conservative maybe we're just that good
maybe we're a Superbowl caliber football
team because of our defense right
nobody's saying that they're gonna win a
RC South but I think you certainly can
make that claim my my we're gonna learn
a lot about the jaguars the next two
weeks all right they go to Carolina and
then they host New Orleans so we'll see
yeah we're gonna see a lot about that
defense the offense
I'm loving Gardner Minshew which I love
their weapons I love their running backs
my issue is that they allowed 5 SEC's of
the Broncos you didn't have a sack
before yesterday's I got some B's but
the Broncos got some guys coming off
course of course the Titans sacked and
though I just worry a lot about that
offensive line and they've been banged
out like they've been the last few years
but I like that one I got to say I got
it won the New Orleans Saints are the
best team in the NFC and are going to
the Super Bowl oh whoa I believe the
Saints have the best offensive line the
NFL in terms of depth in terms of guys
that can get after it I think that they
are the most complete team this is a
team that lost their quarterback went to
Seattle did it with defense special
teams and Alvin Kamara who came home did
not score a touchdown against Dallas and
their defense that people were kind of
worried about where if you really think
about it one of their best offensive
tackles wasn't there in week one when
Houston ran all over them and they've
been completely better
their next four games the four games
that drew brees is supposed to miss
hosting Tampa Bay at home tough game but
very winnable at Jacksonville very
winnable at Chicago if Travis key isn't
there that game is gonna come down to
the wire it's a 50/50 toss-up yeah and
then hosting Arizona I could see them
going three and one over that span if
they go three in one and they're six and
two and Drew Brees gets back the only
game they've lost this year was the game
that Drew Brees got hurt midway through
and that game if the referees don't
screw over the Saints right and they get
that big you know return that's right
they could win that game well I think
that the Saints right now out of all the
teams the NFC I can find a hole in every
team you know I'm big on the Niners yeah
but I believe that the Saints showed me
last night that you can you can't take
away everything they have they are the
most complete team in the NFC and I'm
gonna say this right now to the Saints
fan base that has lambaste in me for
years
and you have come after me and
rightfully so I believe the Saints are
going to the Superbowl
I think the Saints are really good I'm
concerned about them oh one last point
sorry one last point when I watch them
do in the second half was block the
Cowboys pretty much the entire second
half except for that last sack when
Teddy kind of rolled out backwards and
he shouldn't have their offensive line
can block anybody and if Brees has time
you're dead okay here's the thing
and I think I'm shooting my shot I like
that I don't have a problem with that I
think you know you're you're jumping out
there just a bit I think they got a
tough matchup in Tampa Bay this week of
Court decision game Jacksonville Drew
Brees is not back yet that's obviously
gonna be tough in Jacksonville Chicago
at Chicago another another tough game I
would put that as two L's in a row right
there for that football team I'm looking
at the last one up is you get Arizona
and may you get Drew Brees back around
that time I'm concerned the biggest
concern to me is that Teddy Bridgewater
hasn't passed over 195 yards yes in the
game yet now when you're playing against
another quarterback in dak this
figuring things out that may work I'm
concerned that he won't have enough
offense to get things going I think
their defense is playing much better
offensively can they put up enough
points to win those types of shootout
games can they go to Green Bay and do it
there see that's the thing is I think
that what people are overlooking is
we're so used to seeing a Saints team
that wins 31 to 28 and what they don't
realize is this is a sage team that wins
21 18 because their defense is that good
we're just used to seeing the logo and
the color scheme and thinking it's all
offense and so you look at those teams
and you go I don't think Teddy's gonna
have a big game I look at those teams
and go Gardner Minshew is not going to
do anything against this defense chase
Daniels not going to do anything against
this defense and against that Tampa Bay
we're learning a lot about Tim buddy's
gonna be an interesting game but I look
at the Saints team and go I think that
they have a top 500 line on top five
d-line and their defense is so good if
you give Teddy a three-point lead dink
and Duncan dink and a slow death I think
they would have lost the Seattle game if
you don't have a couple of fumbles there
I've got that that's gonna be a Bishu
there I think that you know I like the
things I think they're a really good
football team I don't know that they're
ready and we talked about this a couple
weeks ago wow she's my shot she I'm sure
I like that on what team the NFC do you
have more confidence in them then then
um I of course I would love to see
Seattle but they beat Seattle last week
that's that's number one I would think
that San Fran I want to see what San
Fran does in a way it's something about
that yeah they're on a Bible we'll see
or do you have another shoot your shot
for me yes okay go this this goes in
stark contrast to exactly what you just
said
I think tabby Bay is gonna make the
playoffs I also think that that was it
that was the one dolphin tank that you
didn't buy I was the Bucs may be making
the playoffs I think this is what I
think you're regretting your luck I
think said that they are probably the
best team in the NFC so if you possibly
implode in three weeks that may happen a
week five right now listen
they finally got a running game with
Ronald Jones it's been impressive what
he's done again we saw him do absolutely
nothing last year last 303 of the four
last games over 70 yards rushing he's
averaging thank you $1 bet right now
okay yeah how much do you owe me now a
couple bucks no you [ __ ] owe me a
money just one money that's it a coat
they play the Bucks play at the Saints
yes that's the total gonna host the
Panthers at the Titans at the Seahawk I
like it
I think they leave those four games two
and two or worse I think they're two and
two now they should have beat the Giants
yeah 34 field 34 yard field goal they
would have been three and one right now
they beat Carolina
they beat the Rams they have a chance
listen they do I think that Jameis
Winston is getting better he's
understanding this Bruce Arians offense
a little bit more last two games seven
touchdowns two interceptions he's
starting to understand things you get a
running game you add to that Mike Evans
guess who what he is he's the beast
beast he just goes out say you're a
monster
yeah he just goes out there and runs
past people and jumps over people and we
mentioned the defense already ty listen
they're not at the top in a lot of
different categories but this defense
can play and I think that as a season
continues on this defense would get
better we know that Carolina they
already beat them we know that Atlanta
is done yeah the Saints in that game I
think there's gonna decide who's the
best in the NFC self all right I got a
another I got one that goes against what
you just said shoot your shot the
Carolina Panthers defense will finish
this year as a top 5 defense and this is
what people aren't realizing they are
the best defense in the league's
in terms of points and your excuse
meexcuse excuse me the Patriots are the
number one defense in the league in
points in yards but they're number two
to the Panthers in passing yards allowed
per game the Panthers are allowing less
than a hundred and 60 passing yards a
game right in that game against deshaun
Watson against the Houston offense that
we know could explode they sacked him
six times they hit him 12 times and they
did that without Cohen short the
Carolina Panthers just got Bruce Irvin
back for the first time
they have the ninth best interception
rate they have the best sack rate in the
NFL when a quarterback drops back eight
times the Panthers sack him once so that
means in a normal game either 32 passes
you're getting at least four sacks they
shut down the Rams in week one in the
Bucks game on Thursday night the Bucks
this offense that just hung up 50-plus
on the Rams went to 412 on third down
and they really lost Carolina did more
because of Cam Newton's inability to do
anything on offense than defense they
destroyed Kyler Murray and they
destroyed deshaun Watson Carolina's
defense right now if you listen to what
deshaun Watson said they limit the big
place and they keep everything in front
right same defensive mentality as the
Buffalo Bills this is where Sean
McTernan came from they're inside
linebackers as Shaq Lawson and Kuechly
put him up against anybody in the NFL
yeah they also beat deshaun Watson
without Dante Jackson their fastest
corner but what I said before the year
and the reason that I had Carolina
making the playoffs and I bet them over
in Vegas they the best front seven in
the NFL
I believe the Saints are the best d-line
I believe that the Panthers are the best
front seven Kiwanis or star luteal Ellie
uncle Gerald McCoy Bruce Irvin the the
KITT Brian burns the one they drafted it
I'm missing more guys Kuechly Shaq
Lawson you cannot do anything against
them I think the Panthers will finish
the year with a top five defense I don't
have a problem with that I think I could
certainly go with that I don't have a
problem with that you have a top five
they certainly have the personnel
offense really can't you keep up that's
the question at the fact that Kyle Allen
fumbled three time that's a concern but
but here's my thing is I I look
differently at this [ __ ] if you fumble
three times and you still find a way to
win you're likely not gonna fumble three
times again because you know what
they're gonna do all [ __ ] week hey
Kyle the reporters are asking you if you
have small hands and now he goes when I
roll out instead of being a dumb young
[ __ ]
I'm gonna put two hands on the ball just
like I watched Chris Carson against
Arizona yesterday running with two hands
that's right so the fact that they could
overcome that makes me more impressed
with him do it and you know what Kyle
Allen did I wrote it down because I bet
on Carolina so of course I was very
excited but there was a play where Kyle
Allen played an awful game on the road
but 31 seconds left he's about to get
sacked by JJ Watt and he somehow makes a
man miss ya and throws a first down of
Jarius rightly you can play like [ __ ]
for 59 minutes and 29 seconds but if
your defenses win in the game and
Christian McCaffrey is playing like
[ __ ] Superman all I need you to do is
get that one first down and he did it
and that's where I get excited about
this team because I look at who they've
beaten and who they lost to they lost to
the Rams
yes they lost to the Bucs either those
losses looked that bad right now
well the Rams looks bad but yeah Rams
are [ __ ] great the Rams are so good
they're defensive players will stop
looking at the doggone quarterback and
watch the receiver running past them
then of course I mean you got another
workers I got one more I'll go I got I
got one more and this one's a shot this
is a this is kind of a team that we
talked about a bunch but I think I think
this is true I'm counting them up so one
two obvious three may 3 3 is it maybe so
this team right here okay is either the
the fourth left team in the AFC right
now okay I think that they make the
playoffs and they'll go on a road no
surprise a team in the playoffs okay
provided that they can get their
quarterback back from answering okay you
know no he just got hurt this week no
concussions but he did sprint to the
Shilin yes he's all the bills are one of
my favorites he sprinted to the doggone
but yeah I like that tell me you got a
little great got a little oxy I just
think this team again
I love defenses yes and I love defenses
that are just discipline they just
played the right way
Sean McDermott we talked about him all
the time but I think that he gets guys
to do it the right way
right now they're three and one they had
the easier type of schedule but they
played the champs to to to a close game
1610 in to me when you play games like
this against the best team in the league
one of the best teams in the league that
just provides you more confidence in
what you do this cuz I think one of the
hardest games to pick next week is gonna
be bills at Titan yes
I don't like betting on any game with
the Titans I don't know if they're gonna
look like they did on Sunday and destroy
the Falcons and AJ Brown looks like the
next coming of Julio Jones agent raps
worth yeah huge - they're gonna do what
they did in weeks before and blow a game
to the Indianapolis Colts or come out
and Marcus Mariota looks like crap
against Jacksonville but my question for
you about the bills is when you have a
team and you've been on teams I'm sure
that we're like proven themselves
against the real caliber teams and you
have this emotional release against the
Patriots yeah and then next week you
have to go to Tennessee and you're
feeling huh what is the mental mindset
of a team like Buffalo that just proved
to everybody they can hang with anybody
but now they're on a team that who knows
what we're about well I think naturally
people would think it's a trap game but
Shaun McDormand McDermott would say yeah
no we hung with the Patriots but we
didn't win that can't be the goal just
to get close we're gonna try to keep it
close and in trying to win we had an
opportunity that the goal is to win so
his message to the team is yeah we
haven't done anything yet we beat a
bunch of bunch of average teams so far
we come close to the Patriots and now we
got to go on the road in enemy territory
and and when and so to me a lot of
people would think this is a trap game I
don't believe that I think they go down
and find their way to win because again
it's hard to run against this football
team and it's hard to get your
quarterback back there to throw the ball
down the field for for longer pass
throws the under the over-under for
Buffalo Tennessee next week I'm just
double-checking is the lowest in the NFL
of all the games it is 38 points good
and I don't think that's low enough so
defensive game that game to me is 1613
that game to me is 13 seven well it is
gonna be so [ __ ] ugly that tomorrow's
Mariota is about to get punched in the
face
sanity villes to me especially Joss
Allen plays because now he could run
around if it's close game right let's
face a three-point game went into the
fourth quarter close to the end of the
game now you just need to the waters
back which is interesting yeah now you
just need your quarterback to make a cup
of plays and that could be whether with
his arm or his legs and Josh Allen
healthy Josh Allen can do PO we'll see I
hope Josh Allen plays I think my hope
for Josh Allen is that he can with these
guys and I don't want to put Josh on
this he is a little bit like Jameis I
really hope he can take this time with
this concussion because he isn't the
protocol you'll see what happens if he
gets cleared great if not sit back and
really watch your decision-making
because if you don't turn the ball over
and and you just throw it away
you you have a real chance to win that
game that's right and the Buffalo Bills
can compete with anybody as long as they
don't turn the ball over in Game one
they beat the Jets he had four turnovers
yeah I think they had five turnovers as
a team mm-hmm you beat them 15 14 but
you didn't have to be that close protect
the ball your defense is that good he
has twice as many interceptions as he
has touchdowns three touchdowns six
interceptions the one thing you can't do
we talked to you about it earlier it's
turned the ball over
you're right the defense is just that
good here's what here's a thing if it's
just punt just punt make him go 70 yards
there's my water boy Tim Michaels go
made it make them go 80 yards instead of
30 yeah it's a different game your
defense is that good play to your
defense you don't have to be risky you
don't have to take these types of risk
getting sacked a little bit too much for
my liking to so that's something protect
your quarterback I got one more shooter
shot it's more of an evaluation than a
prediction okay I believe that on Sunday
we are going to witness the biggest gap
in franchise progress in the history of
sports okay the New England Patriots are
facing the Washington Redskins and I
don't believe in the history of sports
we've seen a bigger gap of franchise
growth Washington right now is an
assortment of hired mercenaries team
leaders are refusing to play out of
principle the future of the
franchise was hastily thrown in down 14
against the division rival with no
thought with no care with no week of
preparation they threw him in the game
and said please rookie with no
experience save us yeah that is the
state of the Washington football team
right now the other side
the Patriots I believe of all of their
years of success I believe this is their
highest point of functioning as a
franchise I believe right now Bill
Belichick is hands-down the greatest
coach Talent evaluator salary cap
manager and in-game executor of all time
and right now he is at the peak of his
powers I believe that right now this
level of focus is not just balanced it
is dangerous the defense does not let up
the offense does not let out know the
special teams does not let up their
defense and special teams Brian
Westbrook right now is the 10th highest
scoring player in all of fantasy think
about that it has more points than Zach
Ertz and Allen Robinson combined it has
more points than Keenan Allen Sunday is
going to be a bloodbath
yes sunday is going to be irreconcilable
and I asked the good people of the world
please free Dewayne Haskins save Dewayne
Haskins because what is about to happen
on Sunday is going to be decades in the
making two decades of Bill Belichick
fine-tuning a machine of absolute
destruction and two decades of absolute
nonsense that Dan Snyder has been
building to feed his ego and on Sunday
20 years in the making this is about to
be the ugliest thing you've ever seen in
your entire life I'll tell you this you
know you don't have the Giants handle
the daniel Jones deal they said ok next
game we're gonna put you in will give
you a week of
we're gonna nounce it on Monday so we're
gonna handle all that that's right
and get out of the way to let you get
the game plan yeah because you know
gonna take all the reps at practice it's
important to do that especially for
young guys that have never played a game
in the NFL that's important because then
we want to take care of you we care
about you and we also know that you know
at the end of the day you are the future
face of our franchise and we want to
make sure that you feel good we want you
to make sure that you go out there you
represent yourself well and by the way
we're gonna put you out there and get
some teams that I would think you could
probably take advantage of when you talk
about the Washington team I just think
about and that's my hometown so I'm
hearing it all day long
cousins my uncles my friends they hate
thee they hate this they hate that I
just don't understand what they're doing
to me it started with the trip round
deal you saw what would they got per
Tunsil Trent Williams trip trip with
Tripp Tripp Williams right you're not
gonna use him and even if you were gonna
use him you're not gonna win the
beautiful thing about the Patriots is
that everything they do is not emotional
and not out of ego that's right
this Belichick is willing to move on
from Brady three years ago because he
goes I need to get ahead of this it's
not emotional to write there's new for
the franchise everything Washington has
done for two decades has it been about
Dan Snyder's ego and their emotional and
they don't want to do things that's
right we're not gonna let Kirk Cousins
win franchise him again Trent Williams
we can get something for you gave me
we're emotional we're making you steps
right we want to show people that we can
compete even though we have no structure
whatsoever let's sign land and columns
for 84 million makes no sense we're
taking them from our right no sense
nothing they have done has made sense so
here's the guys it's emotional and it's
ego here's another thing you know what
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we're not gonna fire our coach even
though he stinks you know what though I
think Jay Gruden is not a bad coach I
think they have the worst GM in the NFL
that Bruce Allen had what all those
things are true name the best one but he
has named coach well name the best wide
receiver on the Washington Redskins
maclaurin that's it
a rookie takes it after the second round
I'm the best running back on the
Washington Redskins agent Peterson who
is literally playing because he needs to
afford things because Darius guys got
hurting who's the best lineman on the
Washington Redskins Trent Williams he
used to play not because of Jay Gruden
principle they have a tight end that has
been concussed so many times that were
worried about his health
they paid Alex Smith I'm over and he got
hurt and they don't know why they for
guaranteed it's bad management
they threw like and I am almost positive
that Dwayne Haskins was thrown in not
because of Jay Gruden but because daniel
snyder was sitting there at Giants
Stadium and said I am being embarrassed
in front of the Maris I won Haskins I
don't put this on Jay
to me this feels like Jay might get
another chance later on but bro this is
a franchise that has been shitty since
Daniel Snyder made them go out there and
sign Deion Sanders at 30 years old and
Jason together oh no 1997 why because
you know what Dan Schneider he thought
he knew they were good I want them to
come to my charity galas I want them to
wear this jersey here you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
you're worse than James Dolan you're the
worst owner in sports bad news man I am
now you can just a little motion and I
don't know that they'll win in the
future though cuz they're not part of
winning in the future is being able to
evaluate time at least the Dolphins are
tanking and have a hole well they're
tanking - obviously they're there no no
this is not on purpose
I know I know but you'll give you
literally two million dollars to an in
the Box safety under tagging I agree
they don't even realize they're tanking
that's the worst part they're taking it
don't even realize it
there you know what they are they're a
[ __ ] your joke right there they're uh
they're a rock at the bottom of a fish
tank
yeah they don't even know no don't even
know and they have no waves getting out
they have no way up coming that was
terrible and now as you put yeah I'm
with you I thought everything else I
said there I was pretty good the rock at
the bottom of the fifth where did that
come from well I'm trying to come up
with [ __ ] I was you you you came what
was the only other we're gonna wrap it
up now but the only other thing is that
I definitely want to kind of give a
shout out
- is shout out to clowny coming out
there make an impact right away I like
Cuban shouts the defensive guys shout
out to my cahide Lattimore - mark
damarious Randall Devin McCourty
Jermaine white Heather Browns at a great
game again it was good to see Landry and
chub it was good to see
shout out to my guide Travis Kelce be
listening little credible ah I tell I'll
let you guys it I texted this morning
and I said bro that was so [ __ ] cool
to watch and he goes man we're just
having fun out there but wha and I said
I grew up when Randy Moss lobbed it back
on that play before the half we
celebrated him as a genius in the game
that's right and I said bro it's so cool
that you pulled a moss and he responded
to me and he goes the lateral is
probably the most underutilized play in
football and I said you know Bill
Belichick had asked calm the [ __ ] down
and we were laughing about it but I go
it's just such a heads-up play when your
offense is clicking and it's going that
slow motion that you can even have the
presence of mind no it was so cool -
it's easy this is the most remarkable
part of that play to me it's easy to do
that in practice it's easy to do that
when you're up by 50 you're just kind of
messing around they needed that drive
yes they needed to go down and score not
only that if you really watch the play
mahomes rules right and no one's open he
wasn't and Kelsey so not only did he
have the heads up to run across the
field to find space yeah to then catch
it and immediately process that [ __ ]
nut
wasn't he ee once he double-team that to
begin in their play he may have but some
reason I think he was double-team they
kind of left him yeah then he just kind
of wandered around found their opening
and McCoy I text him this morning like
holding the ball like you know told
Walters hatin job hey he's a good player
how's he feeling right now is he just
loving life loser Sean he loves life
because you know he was in torture up
there in Buffalo for a long time just
didn't have a lot of talent around me
now around him now he's with his old
coach he's with some guys that can win
yeah and they're winning football games
so anytime you win makes a big
difference guys a lot of overreactions
right now on the NFL a lot of upsets
happened you know which podcast told you
that Buffalo in Detroit is probably
going to cover the line
you know which podcast is letting you
have it straight do not worry about the
over reactors why we take advantage of
them and we bet against them we're gonna
have plenty of information with you as
this week goes on for Brian Westbrook
the rocket man Oh explain it now is your
time yeah the rocket man them went back
back in the day when I was playing
football and all my good plays they
would play the little cartoon and it was
a rocket man back in the day you should
know this if you had the Eagles game but
I never went to the Eagles guts that's
even worse I'm not I'm out on you know I
watched football games on television
like a sane person yeah who the [ __ ]
wants to go to the game no I'll watch
eight games at one time yeah they have
their brethren all right now give it up
for the for the t-shirt toss not [ __ ]
interested changing the channel on the
lef koe man and we will how much you
guys later enjoy the games people
[Music]